[Applause]
there might be a new goat on the block
bro
on a comedy block there might be a new
goat on the comedy block
bill burr did an snl monologue
in front of snl's super
like trust fund white woman audience
yeah right and he did it bill burr
style my man was bill burr all the way
through gilbert through and through
and killed in arguably the worst
audience in comedy
murdered with his own material didn't
pander at all
i think he might be to go with straight
skill and manipulation i want to break
down like how he got these people
that have no sense of humor to laugh at
actual real jokes that are offensive
but we got to start having a
conversation there might be a new goat
in town
he right now might be the best he i
think he's the best comic working right
now in this moment yeah i include
chappelle in that which is lofty oh see
now i was separating chappelle
whoa i was put chappelle's almost like
um because
chappelle is kind of doing his own thing
right now that isn't really stand up in
the sense
it's like whatever his um george floyd
special was that wasn't comedy
right you can't say hannah gatsby's not
comedy and then say chappelle is in that
special
they are a similar thing they're not
really comedy
they're trying to say something right
bill burr that's comedy
so i think in this moment right now what
he is doing is more stand up than what
chapelle is doing and he's the best
donor right now how about this just for
the sake of discussion we take chappelle
out okay
just take chappelle out chappelle's the
goat goated
on mount rushmore of comedy nobody could
touch him
god status while he's still alive very
few comics get to have that
you know there's a lot of comics that we
revere after they're dead like a lenny
bruce type you know we've got
lenny somewhere there he is we got lenny
in the studio right now but
and pryor probably got it while he was
alive but definitely after he was alive
probably even more so he's like the
jay-z of comedy
where you're getting your flowers while
you're still
i don't know rapping or you're still
doing your art yeah if you will
um so if we're looking at just pure
comics in that way bill burr what he did
on snl if you guys haven't seen it go
watch it it's on youtube
it's on twitter's on whatever the [ __ ]
it is but it was masterful man
and the way that he came out and the way
that he got this crowd
on his side i thought was absolutely
brilliant go ahead okay
so if you guys don't know bill burr you
can look up his jokes there's nothing
likable about his takes yeah at all is
maybe the least likable premises that
exist
100 percent which you know we love i
mean that's the idea behind inside jokes
right when we're doing inside jokes that
show is like how do we take the most
[ __ ] up premises and make them funny
you'd agree it's the idea behind
flagrant too
absolutely absolutely 100 so we have
this
we have he goes up and the first joke he
actually does
you think the audience thinks he's on
their side yes
right so the first joke is wear a mask
right and if you don't wear a mask good
you'll die
and it goes into his feeling where we
need less people we're overpopulated
we're overpopulated we need less people
so
the woke audience is like well i don't
want to laugh at people dying but
i do like that he wants people to wear
masks and you're supposed to wear masks
because that's what fauci tells me and i
just regret to say whatever foul she
tells me so
okay i can laugh at this guy he's good
he goes we can get less people
get rid of the people it'll be the best
possible thing in the world
it'll be what is what is the exact line
he says i forgot he says
uh he goes it was a dream come true he
goes something like that it'll be
it's a dream come true less people he
goes talking about dreams come true
did you guys see rick moranis
oh my god that transition was so [ __ ]
good beautiful right
so now he's rope and dope he go and this
is my favorite part right so now the
woke audience is like am i allowed to
laugh at this i'm not sure if i'm
allowed to
a man was punched now it is a man that's
punched so it's kind of okay to laugh at
white man
this white man is punched but he is
smaller can we laugh at that we're not
exactly sure
and then he says this he goes he goes
new york is back
baby when he goes new york is back
all the people in the audience who
identify as new yorkers because they've
still been in new york they didn't go
back home for whatever reason
i assume that they're not actual new
yorkers because we don't go to snl
yeah they are 100 building you know 100
percent transformation yeah exactly
right
so uh so basically they lose it because
finally there's somebody that has their
back that's saying publicly new york is
back
you know i think it feeds into even if
you're like the most left-wing guy you
got crazy pride in new york
you're probably not born here but you
still really take a lot of pride in
being a new yorker yeah and then when he
says new york is back
you feel tougher you identify as a place
you're not born in you have even more
pride right like you're
compensating yeah yeah 100 um perfect
example
perfect example i'm super indian because
i
don't have to risk getting raped you
know what i mean like i'm just in there
i mean i'm here
comfy love it you're right and then you
feel tougher when somebody says oh a guy
got punched in new york new york is back
you're like
oh i'm from a tough city me super left
wing glass is wearing [ __ ] is
tough for living here
[ __ ] yeah new york is back coming on the
heels of rock's performance
which i watched i didn't watch before
and i watched i think you were hard on
him
same i thought that this was the
difference i saw
i thought that he had a few really good
roast jokes up front
right like the first thing he said i
thought was funny where he was like you
know
uh let's not acknowledge the elephant in
the room donald trump is
in the hospital right now with covid and
i you know my thoughts and prayers go
out for kovid
yeah i thought it was a funny joke yeah
it what it is here's the thing
it acknowledges what everybody's
thinking in the moment
in a clever way and anytime you do that
it's amazing
okay on the spot we're not talking about
he worked that joke out for months he
didn't know he's going to be in the
hospital for a month but you got to open
up something with whatever
i thought he had a funny couple funny
rose in the front
what i will say is this chris rock
didn't do
and maybe he's changed but like it
seemed to me
like chris rock was doing what he
thought the
snl audience would like not
what he wanted he was like what will
kill in front of them
let's do these jokes not pandering per
se
but definitely not him him going hard
but maybe he's changed maybe he's grown
maybe he's become like more mature where
he cares about these things
so i'll say like so that was my initial
feeling and then the other thing i felt
when i was watching him was like
it was classic rock premises that were
really strong
but one punch line and then move on i
think if you want to talk about
if you want to talk about having to work
out material for a longer time
100 if he worked on material for a long
time i think he'd add more punchlines
but like
for me i look at chris rock i'm like
this is a brilliant guy that chose to
put his brilliance into comedy
and then there are certain guys that are
just hysterical guys that learn how to
do stand up
i don't think he's like a naturally
funny guy i think he's a naturally
brilliant guy
that found a way to hack stand up oh
yeah i thought he had a similar issue
but you it's more glaring than
as asber because they didn't have enough
time to work it out but burr we've sat
in a car with burr
he's kind of just bill burr like he's
just being bill burr the whole time he's
talking
you've talked to rock more than me but
from what i know he is not
chris rock on stage off stage no he's
those are very different people he's
just brilliant he got to put in a lot of
work off state or like a stage after
stage to get to chris rock
that we know doing specials yeah he's
got a fake voice
yeah i just like you do that when you're
like when you're looking at it almost
like a scientist you're like what other
mechanism do i need to
induce more laughter you know what i
mean like he's really kind of
looking i think chris rock is just an
absolute genius
like an absolute genius that found
stand-up comedy and i think
burr is just like a hysterical dude
just like a funny guy that learned the
article i think he's a blue collar
just dude who found stand up comedy and
he's funny
and smart as [ __ ] but rock is it's a
different life if he wasn't
intelligent he'd be doing drywall like
and these women think they got it hard
perfect put up the [ __ ] drywall that
girl's at home right now
doing dishes i'd rather do dishes than
putting up this drug like i think that
that's the exact same guy
and i think that's why he like it things
resonate so much with people on like a
lizard level
and it's so funny the reaction of it the
exact group of people that he went after
the woke white women got pissed yep and
who was supporting the [ __ ] out of it
black people oh yeah probably that's the
funniest thing
right like all over all over twitter
like
all these like black activists being
like oh this bill bird thing is great
is it like roasts their two favorite
things to make fun of which are
uppity white chicks yeah
perfect like what's the problem for real
dude it was just
it was just also black people enjoy edgy
comedy
and so i guess i was disappointed with
chris because it wasn't that edgy
like normally especially politics talks
he'll get pretty edgy
with it and like i kind of felt like you
said he was going for the christmas
was trying to do well he didn't want to
bomb yeah
was like you know what i'm going for it
that's what i'm saying yeah and chris at
that level you should go for you got to
go for it
who was chris's last stand up uh maybe a
few years ago he came out with one a few
years ago
was it good one drop the first half was
awful i'm
last year right now first half was awful
second half was really good
but he's in an interesting transition
where i think he's trying to shed the
head right i think he thinks he's played
or whatever personally i still love it
but i think he feels like he's too old
or it's too old or something because his
whole career flipped
he used to do jokes telling in a regular
voice
and he was doing fine but then when he
came out we'll bring the pain and he
started talking like
all [ __ ] is different whole career
changes the whole trajectory of his
career changes
what's so funny
maybe that really works for black people
maybe the whole time
he was talking regular black people like
i'll get this corny skinny [ __ ]
the second he was like
what do you mean
it works bro i can't even help myself
what the [ __ ] is so funny she's laughing
you're making the exact same page we
make this is so funny